Sonic the Hedgehog
you're no match for me
this is your moment to be the big hero
oh great the Winter Soldier
my destiny to destroy you
work smarter not harder
that wasn't too bad
Sonic the Hedgehog 2 April 8th
foreign
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
Sonic I love that you want to help make
a difference
you're being Reckless don't worry
pretending to be Batman blue justice
trademark pending
he was still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you I just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
Oprah
Papa's Got a Brand New stash
since I've been gone I've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two I have no idea
it wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for day 100
chance of Adventure
foreign
do I look like I need your power
where are my manners Sonic meat knuckles
[Music]